dave chappelle i know he has these shows
he does in ohio he has an outdoor
kind of uh theater that he set up and uh
i saw letterman was down there
chris rock went down there a lot of the
comics are going down there i didn't
know
that you had gone down there to do a
show i was driving across country
uh over the summer with a couple of
girlfriends
and we were going through ohio so i
stopped for a night and
stayed there and did a set and it was
really
really fun it was like michelle wolfe
was there
and ali wong was there and danelle
rawlings who used to be on chelsea
lately all the time so i hadn't seen him
in years so it was a really fun group of
people
and i mean he's created like a whole
city down there
and you get tested when you get there
and then you get a bracelet and everyone
in the bracelet is able to like mingle
and he sets up this bar
for after that's like at it's like a
disco from the 70s it's just so
much fun and everyone just parties to
like six in the morning so
[ __ ] yeah i had to get the [ __ ] out of
there after the first night because i
was like
whoa whoa whoa whoa i can't operate like
that anymore
i'm dying to understand this the
chappelle put you up for the night in
other words does you have a compound
there of some sort that
you can sleep over yeah he has a house
and a guest house and i have my dogs
with me
my rich white lady dogs as they refer to
them as um
yeah i spent the night at his guest
house
and um and and yeah i did a set and then
i
left in the morning so i was like there
for about 24 hours which was fun
and uh yeah everyone stays in hotels i
guess and there's
everyone like there's comics that have
moved down there because that's the only
stage time there's really has been you
know
so there's like a group of comics that
are down there
no kidding i didn't know yeah thinking
about buying property and stuff so i
think maybe chappelle has some
i mean maybe he's gonna turn it into
something bigger one day i mean
he could i mean people 450 people every
night drive in
for it